[Musique]
catherine deneuve nous fait donc le
plaisir d'assister à ce journal pour
parler du dernier métro le dernier métro
c'est un film qui sort demain sur les
écrans il est signée françois truffaut
catherine deneuve en est le personnage
principal je dirais même beaucoup plus
que ça puisque dans ce rôle à mes yeux
elle personnifie la femme la femme de
toutes les époques
la femme qui fait face à toutes ses
responsabilités sans pour autant
renoncer à la recherche du bonheur
le dernier métro cela évoque aussi pour
beaucoup d'entre vous les années
d'occupation à paris il ne fallait
surtout pas rater le dernier mais toi
pour le spectacle spectacle
soigneusement surveillées par la
propagande nazie et ses plus fervents
collaborateurs on chassait les juifs
dans les théâtres et dans toute la
culture le chantage était roi françois
truffaut présente ainsi son film un film
d'amour et l' aventure qui exprime notre
aversion pour toutes les formes de
racisme et d'intolérance
mais aussi notre affection profonde pour
ceux qui ont choisi le métier de
comédien et l'exercent par tous les
temps nous allons voir d'abord un court
extrait du dernier métro vous êtes la
directrice du théâtre catherine deneuve
et gérard depardieu vous annonce qu'il
vous quitte pour entrer dans la
résistance puis vous m'intimides y ait
parfois vous ne regardiez sévèrement et
même avec une certaine dureté
je vous assure je me sentais juger tout
le contraire j'étais troublé par l'ons
oui c'est vrai j'étais troublé comme
j'avais l'impression que tout le monde
allait venir sur mon visage
alors j'aime bien aussi c'est la france
vous avez à me détester
je ne vous ai jamais détesté mais je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi vous étiez
devenu si distante après avoir embrassé
121 pas forcément sur la bouche
moi je vous embrasse et sur l'avenue
oui le soir de la générale pendant l'aïd
ou non sûrement pas vous m'avez embrassé
sur la bouche même pas qu'il ya deux
femmes en moi si justement
alors voilà la question y at il deux
femmes en vous oui je pense qu'il ya de
femmes en moi mais comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure j'ai beaucoup
de femmes peut-être un peu plus chez les
actrices et là dans ce film précisément
vous avez 7
cette dualité que j'ai essayé d'évoquer
tout à l'heure en parlant de
responsabilité et aussi de on annonce
pas pour ça à la recherche de
l'attirance la recherche du bonheur oui
c'est exact parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui comme tous les acteurs delà de cette
troupe à ce moment-là essaye de monter
un spectacle qui malgré le plaisir de
monter quelque chose que l'on aime et de
participer à une pièce que l'on aime ne
peuvent pas s'empêcher de subir quand
même les contraintes politiques
tellement lourde et peut-être pour
marion steiner personnage que j'incarne
dans le film directrice du théâtre un
peu plus longue puisqu'elle est
directrice de ce théâtre est
provisoirement que ce n'est pas son
métier qu'elle remplace son mari
provisoirement étant juif obligé de se
cacher et qu'il a donc nommé en son
absence directrice du théâtre on va pas
raconter le film mais vous aimez votre
mari mais attirés aussi par un comédien
oui c'est exact j'aime mon mari et je
suis attiré par un comédien et plus je
suis attiré par lui plus j'essaie je
crois de contrôler cette attirance qui
est difficile disons que c'est une
impulsion que j'essaie de retenir parce
que j'ai des responsabilités plus plus
grave et plus lourde à supporter plus un
secret que je porte pendant longtemps
tout seul ce qui est ce qui rend ce
personnage par moments assez froid est
assez distant puisque on sent que c'est
quelqu'un qui a quand même peur de se
laisser aller et que ce serait très
grave
oui parce que c'est un secret est très
lourd et que le partage et représentent
un risque plus grand que de le porter
tout seul
un des personnages de votre du film
c'est une femme éclate en sanglots tout
à coup au milieu du film est dit mais
c'est pas possible que ce qu'elle peut
être dur avec moi alors est-ce que vous
avez conscience que d'abord est ce que
est ce que vous avez conscience que vous
pouvez apparaître peut-être même au
cinéma comme dans la vie dure alors que
vous nous les palettes sais pas je crois
que je ne veux pas l'être c'est que je
crois que je ne suis pas mais comme tous
les gens qui sont un peu réservé ce qui
est souvent difficilement compatible
avec le métier que je fais disons que
j'ai du mal
j'ai du mal à montrer ce que je voudrais
montrer centre ou le montrer c'est je
suis réservé de nature et par moments ça
peut prendre un visage un peu peut-être
à la limite même antipathique c'est vrai
je suis pas quelqu'un de très expansif
surtout avec les gens que je ne connais
pas bien voilà mais c'est quelque chose
qui vous va au coeur ça quand on vous
dit peut-être dur avec moi et cette
phrase dans le film parce que moi ce
elle me va très bien et c'est une des
phrases les plus durs sur le personnage
même je crois qu'elle ajoute elle ne
pardonne jamais rien dans l'histoire en
tant que je vous dis avec une certaine
tristesse quand même parce que c'est pas
vraiment mais c'est une des phrases
c'est vrai les plus les plus durs mais
c'est un personnage un peu dur mario si
c'est vrai mais dures comme les gens qui
ne peuvent pas passer trop de temps
quand on a beaucoup de choses à faire
indépendamment de ces raisons
personnelles comme c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de choses à faire dans la vie
courante dans la journée c'est quelqu'un
on sent qu'il ne peut pas consacrer
beaucoup de temps à chacun d'ailleurs un
moment elles sont plaints en dix ans
c'est injuste et on lui dit elle c'est
que c'est comme ça mais on lui reproche
finalement de ne pas être présente et ne
pas consacrer à chacun du temps parce
que mario est quelqu'un de sincère et
qu'elle ne fait pas semblant donc ne
pouvant pas faire semblant elle préfère
passer sur quelque chose d'autre qui lui
semble plus important et tout est
relatif vous n'avez pas bien sûr connu
cette période de l'occupation ans
j'aurais pu mais je crois avec truffaut
découvert toute une époque sur les très
documenté très documenté et ça faisait
très longtemps qu'il avait envie de
tourner un film qui se passerait à ce
moment là moi je me souviens qu'il ya
déjà très longtemps qu'il m'avait parlé
d'un projet qu'il essayait de trouver le
film qui se prêterait le mieux à cette
époque très particulière qui mélangerait
à la fois la vie le théâtre l'amour
l' aventure et surtout dans ce contexte
répressif de l'occupation à paris oui
puis j'ai découpé en public après au
moment de la libération
on a beaucoup critiqué les gens qui
avaient continué à jouer au théâtre
certains oui je crois que c'est toujours
c'est facile pour moi de dire évidemment
qu'on trouve toujours des excuses à aux
acteurs mais c'est difficile d'abord
parce que je me dis c'était à traiter
plein vous avez que s'étaient plaints
parce que les gens jouaient mais je
crois que c'est facile de dire après on
a continué à jouer ils ont continué à
s'amuser sur sans doute il ya eu des
gens irresponsables sans doute ya eu des
gens qui ont été responsables mais je
pense qu'il y en a qui ont joué dans des
conditions plus plus grave que d'autres
et je pense qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas qui ne se sont pas donné un
spectacle qui n'ont pas distrait les
autres qui ont fait des choses bien plus
redoutable et d'une façon plus anonyme
alors c'est vrai que les gens de
spectacle sont toujours visés plus vite
plus haut plus rapidement c'est bien de
travailler avec françois truffaut
ah oui c'est très bien dans quel sens
est-ce que c'est très bien mais j'ai
toujours joué oui vous avez raison mais
j'ai toujours remarqué en lisant des
surtout d'interviews d'acteurs étrangers
d'actrice plus particulièrement que
c'était un des metteurs en scène
européens qui était le plus aimée et
avec lequel les femmes particulièrement
avait le plus envie de tourner et je
partage en connaissance de cause leurs
leur envie que moi j'ai pu en tous les
cas assouvir parce que celle d'un oui
toutes les chances oui parce que c'est
un metteur en scène qui aime beaucoup
les femmes et que beaucoup de metteurs
en scène croit aimer les femmes et même
les actrices c'est quelqu'un qui aime
avant tout les femmes et je trouve que
ça se sent et jeu on sent bien que les
femmes le centre est une chose que les
femmes sont très bien aussi
deux s'accordent oui il connaît il aime
les femmes je trouve que c'est évident
on se sent en confiance on est on se
laisse aller beaucoup plus facilement
avec quelqu'un qui en a complètement
confiance une dernière question est ce
que vous êtes tenté par le théâtre dit
donc je n'ai pas encore vraiment une
envie très grande voix du théâtre parce
qu'il m'est difficile de d'affronter le
public directement
c'est une des choses qui me retient le
plus je trouve que vous n'êtes pas mal à
la télévision est ce que vous n'auriez
pas une dramatique pour nous par hasard
pas pour l'instant mais j'ai eu un
projet qui reprendra peut-être oui merci
catherine deneuve
[Musique]